- I'm Brandon McManus,
and this is Build Your Squad.
(upbeat music)
I got $15 to build my all-time favorite
Chiefs and 49ers squad.
OK, so it's a great
list here of players,
and I'll start with the quarterback
because obviously they get things going.
Joe Montana's great, Steve Young is great,
but at the value of $3
I gotta go with Patrick Mahomes.
He's an incredible star, MVP last year,
he's got 'em back to the Super Bowl,
so $3 down the drain there.
I got $12 left.
Running back is tough,
I mean these are some great, great names.
I think Marcus Allen,
I still think he has
some juice down there.
You know, he's with the Chiefs, so,
a Hall of Famer himself,
so I'm gonna go with Marcus Allen.
Even if he's in the
back end of his career,
he's still was an awesome, awesome player.
Two more dollars down the drain.
So I apply to all, I got $10 left.
And we got receivers or tight ends here.
Hall of Famer, Hall of
Famer, Hall of Famer,
immaculate catch, and future
superstar here, Tyreek Hill.
For the value of a dollar,
the speed he's got,
I gotta go with Tyreek Hill.
One more dollar, I know it's
cheap but sorry, $1 toss.
And then I'm gonna skip the corner
to see how much money I got left,
but Derrick Thomas was a
special, special player.
An all-time great, he
and my boy Von Miller,
I'm best friends with,
he idolized Derrick Thomas,
so I gotta give $5 for him.
So, costly, but he's an all-time great.
So there's five more.
So, I got $4 left for the safety,
so I go with my man Eric Berry here.
Recovered from cancer, incredible player,
deserves everything he needs to do.
Was one of the best safeties ever.
So that's $15,
my all-time 49ers-Chiefs team.
I got quarterback Patrick
Mahomes, Tyreek Hill,
Marcus Allen, Derrick
Thomas and Eric Berry.
I just realized they're all Chiefs.
I apologize 49ers fans,
but this is my all time $15 squad.